so a ob get a tattoo of a teardrop
beneath your right eye
get walked in on every time you go to
the bathroom
every single time oh
you'd never think there were random
choices would you
they sound like okay yeah they're about
either yeah
um get a teardrop tattoo or get walked
in on
every single time i go piss or [ __ ]
that matters every single time you go to
the bloody hell
uh yeah just like different people every
time
okay it just says get walked in on
people
i read in a rule book you can you can
make a scenario behind it
you know so yes so when you said i'm
walking on different people 100 is
different people
every single oh no matter what happens
i'm just getting no matter what happens
if you're going in there to piss if
you're going in there to [ __ ]
look at yourself in the mirror or you
just take a [ __ ] someone's walking in on
you
even if you've locked it even if you've
checked that you blocked it so
it's exactly like it's exactly like the
animated one we did
where you were at the girl's yard you're
taking a [ __ ] and he did
he looked back and you saw the three
dudes
hilarious hilarious but yeah walking on
you
every single damn time teardrop or
teardrop teardrop
teardrop teardrop okay because
there there are some pros to getting the
teardrop okay
like i can strike fear in people okay
and even if i don't imagine you don't
i'm not people think i'm an idiot oh god
like the teardrop is just like i at
least i can get on with my day-to-day
life yeah but i just couldn't deal with
that
yeah i'm just trying to take a [ __ ] and
it's a different person
all the time ah yeah yeah
bro i couldn't handle it
these things for me always boil down to
the psychological effects yeah
yeah what kind of psychological
psychological trauma am i gonna go
through
yeah dealing with this and i'll just
have to get the teardrop
people will just grow accustomed to this
yeah but every single
time girl's walking in on me you're on
your seven kids are walking in on me
my mom's walking in on me colleagues at
work are walking in on me
that's where i draw the line actually
colleen's i'll hunt you get the teardrop
soon as a colleague at work walks in on
me bro that only happened to me one time
i kicked the door shut and then i
couldn't tell him it was me
you had to wait for him to leave before
you scurried out the toilet yeah yeah
so at work i was just sitting there my
belly was hurting yeah i had the bus
yes so i'll just sit in there and i'll
just you know you're just rocking yeah
yeah yeah
i must have forgot to lock the door
donny walked in
this thing at my work um it's not even a
bathroom
so it's not a bathroom cubicle thing
okay there is a
door which is a toilet so it's basically
like a concrete cubicle
so you could be in the middle of a
hallway okay you open the door as if
you're walking into a bathroom
but it's just a toilet and sink and
stuff in there okay so it's like a
miniature bathroom okay
so you literally push the door and
you're in the toilet
and where is that situated where's this
door situated is that it oh it's in the
building
it's in the comp communal hallway like
getting hidden away
nah they didn't think about that so
donny goes to
open the door and i'm just rocking there
and it gets like
this far open so he can't see like the
light is like here yeah so you can't see
me fam you can see you can see one
you can see one foot there and i had to
boot the ting shot
i was just like ah and he must have
smacked him and he was like oh sorry
and i wanted to be like it's cool sorry
but i was like i can't speak because
then he's gonna know oh there's james in
there
so literally the door's here yeah he
opens
kick it sharp he's like sorry kept my
mouth up so you think he's probably
thinking rude prick
i lock the door he goes back in the
office and i'm
i'm in there for ages now because i'm
thinking if i come out straight away he
might be waiting for me to come out
and i don't want to know it with him to
know it was me that just kicked the door
in his face
and i was just waiting there for ages if
i finished my [ __ ] just sat there
thinking what do i do what do i do
and i thought i left and he wasn't out
there and i thought
i can't even go back in the office now
because i'm the only one that's been in
here
because this toilet's the closest to my
office so i'm the only one i can't even
go back in there
for him to be like i was james you know
what i mean so i have to go to the
canteen
i'm walking around and bought myself a
dr pepper i'm doing backflips to make
sure that i'm not the next person that
walks back into
there's no way i could have that every
day there's no way i could deal with
that every day
no way all right guys
i was gonna ask you what you would do oh
yeah i can still answer though
i would definitely go for the tattoo
yeah because [ __ ] for me
isn't a sprint yeah i like to take my
you know my phone i like to chill i just
don't like to rush it and this is one of
the main reasons why
i tend to not i only have a tent to [ __ ]
at home yeah i don't really tend to
share work
i couldn't get walked in on every single
time after bro
no no no and because i'm dark skinned as
well the teardrop you'd have to be
a bit close to it yeah so i've got a bit
of fire bless
is it the right way wrong